>>> IT HAPPENED AGAIN.
I THOUGHT IT WAS BEHIND ME, BUT
THE DREAMS CAME BACK.
I WAS UP ALL NIGHT.
I CAN'T EAT.
I CAN'T SLEEP.
>> WHAT'S WRONG?
>> IT HAUNTS ME.
>> OH, STEVEN NOT THIS AGAIN.
>> I FORGOT ABOUT IT FOR YEARS,
BUT THEN I REMEMBERED THAT
AVATAR, THE GIANT INTERNATIONAL
BLOCKBUSTER, USED THE PAPYRUS
FONT AS IT'S LOGO.
>> AVATAR, LIKE, THAT MOVIE FROM
NINE YEARS AGO?
>> YEAH, HE JUST HIGHLIGHTED
AVATAR, HE CLICKED THE DROP DOWN
MENU, AND THEN HE RANDOMLY
SELECTED PAPYRUS.
LIKE A THOUGHTLESS CHILD
WANDERING BY A GARDEN YANKING
LEAVES ALONG THE WAY.
>> AND SO NOW YOU ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THE SEQUELS THAT ARE
COMING OUT?
>> THEY ARE MAKING MORE?
>> YEAH, WELL, I THINK I HEARD
THAT.
>> THEY CHANGED THE ARTWORK.
THEY FIXED IT.
>> IT LOOKS SIMILAR.
>> HE JUST GOT AWAY WITH IT.
THIS MAN, THIS PROFESSIONAL
GRAPHIC DESIGNER.
WAS IT LAZINESS?
WAS IT CRUELTY?
>> YOU SHOWED ME THIS BEFORE.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS LITERALLY
PAPYRUS.
MAYBE THAT WAS THE STARTING
POINT BUT THEY CLEARLY MODIFIED
THIS.
>> BUT WHATEVER THEY DID, IT
WASN'T ENOUGH!
AND NOW HERE I AM DOING WHAT I
VOWED TO NEVER DO AGAIN, SITTING
OUTSIDE HIS HOUSE, HOPING TO
CATCH A GLIMPSE OF HIM TO SEE
HIM DOING HIS LITTLE THINGS,
LIVE HIS INSANE LITTLE LIFE.
I THINK ABOUT IT EVERY TIME I
SEE PAPYRUS.
>> OKAY.
WHERE ELSE DO YOU EVEN SEE THIS
FONT?
>> HOOKAH BARS.
TEQUILA MERCH OFF BRAND TEES.
SHAKIRAM MERCH.
>> MY GOD.
ARE YOU OKAY?
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> DO YOU REMEMBER THE AVATAR
LOGO.
>> YEAH.
IT WAS TRIBAL YET FUTURISTIC.
>> PAPYRUS.
>> SURE.
>> I KNOW WHAT YOU DID.
I KNOW WHAT YOU DID!
[ LAUGHTER ]
[ APPLAUSE ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]